so Kingston's hello
okay we're on here YouTube through a
curve at me they change their interface
so I a little while figuring out how
this all works so today I want to talk
about tutors and why I tutor is
important and of course you know that
let's make sure that I've got this sound
off here okay yeah I keep track of the
questions on my iPad and I sometimes
forget to commute it now you know that I
am a proponent of input as the the best
way to get the language into you that is
reading listening in some review of
words and occasional you know looking at
some of the grammar rules not to try to
remember them but just to try to explain
some of the things that you're coming
across in the language and many of these
things we know this right but we
sometimes need to be righted for example
and that's all the tutor the tutor is
forced first and foremost is a source of
encouragement and stimulus we need to be
motivated to learn now the tutor needed
be the only source of motivation if I
meet a Korean person somewhere and say a
few words in Korean then I'm sure all of
a sudden I'm motivated Jesus I really
should do something about improving my
career so the motivation could be a
random encounter with someone it could
be a movie my wife is watching this
Turkish soap opera on Netflix and yeah I
want to get a Turkish so there's any
number of things that can be motivating
but I think the tutor is is a very good
one because so right now I'm doing two
innocent I need a challenge I'm doing
two languages Arabic and Persian
you know it's difficult to pull yourself
away I've been on Arabic now I'm gonna
go to Persian but the fact that I have
an encounter with my tutor is is
motivating a guy get my Persian back up
to a level or I can at least carry on a
conversation so it motivates me and I
look forward to seeing my tutors whether
I'm going from my Arabic to my person
tutor or from my person tutor back to my
Arabic to your both of them are
excellent tutors very encouraging they
know how to keep the conversation going
it's it's too much of a burden for the
learner to come on with all kinds of
things that the learner wants to talk
about so the tutor has to be very good
at keeping the conversation going and of
course not and finding that right level
of sort of correction in fact I prefer I
simply get a report they're going to
show you a report that I got from a
tutor and so that that picks up on some
of the things that I had trouble with
the tutor can also point out something
like many a thing of the things that the
grammar book explains I mean they fall
into a sort of different categories some
of the things they explain you simply
don't understand because you haven't had
any experience with it before so for
example early on in the arabic
explanation they'll tell you that you
know the plural of inanimate things
takes the feminine singular like this
you hear it up for the first time i say
that a that can't be and B you don't
really understand and you don't really
focus on so in Arabic the relative
pronoun who or which is Allah T for
feminine singular for masculine singular
and alladhina for plural masculine
because plural anything else inanimate a
saw
yeah a little for people but if it's
inanimate if it's a thing then it goes
back to ality which is the feminine
singular well I've been merrily charging
along in Arabic having read that
exclamation some long time ago it hasn't
register on me at all I don't really
notice it while I'm in the language
because it's so much stuff is happening
so many new words I am I don't really
necessarily identify nouns as masculine
and feminine although it's not that
difficult to do but it's still not
clicking in for me and so the tutor
points this out to me like wow yeah ok
and now because I have wondered why is
it Allah be ality alladhina and now she
explains it and it's probably the third
or fourth time that I get that
explanation but it now comes at a time
when I'm receptive to that explanation
because it's something now that I've
started to focus on because I'm not you
know I'm other things have fallen into
place now I'm in a position to receive
that explanation so and the tutor the
tutor I have four Arabic she's very good
she doesn't force stuff on me she
certainly doesn't ask me to perform
after she's explained it she just gently
explains things some of these things
still some don't and we always have a
very interesting conversation and the
the you know I have a twice a week with
Arabic and once a week with Persian but
even if I'm on one language and after
your three tutoring sessions we which is
or it can be difficult to fit into my
schedule I got a whole bunch of other
stuff I'm doing that's not enough
speaking to become a good speaker okay
that's the first thing if you if you
want to speak well you have to speak a
lot and so if you have a lot of time and
a lot of money you can line up five
hours a day of speaking and that will be
enough speaking to make a difference but
the speaking that I do is more of a kind
catalyst so it stimulates me I want to
you know prepare myself for the next
session with my tutor it reminds me that
I better crank it if I'm moving from one
language to the other I gotta crank my
level up I mean there's no question that
if I've been listening for it to an hour
or two of whatever person Arabic I'm
gonna do better in the session with my
tutor and nobody likes to do poorly no
we don't do as well as we would like and
we do better sometimes than others but
then I see I get this report and then I
can listen to it many times and then I
can once again review it and I still
forget a lot of the new vocabulary
that's there but it's all part of the
process and I can go back as I'll show
you - my conversation reports that I've
received and I can review them from like
three months ago and so this is also
content so I treat the session with my
tutor as a place for encouragement for
stimulus for some explanation which
might be more alive and more timely than
the explanation I get out of the book
there is some speaking but the amount of
speaking is not that great but at least
it's some didn't it somehow seems to
make me more alert when I'm listening
and reading so it ups my level of focus
when I'm listening and reading but
ultimately I'm relying on my input to
improve my language skills and hope that
one day I will be in a situation in
Persian or Arabic where I will be able
to speak more in Persian that
opportunity will present itself when I
go back to my Kluwer because there are
simply so many person speakers you know
thank to her Arabic speakers not so many
but when I was in Morocco I was in taxis
with people and we were having all kinds
of conversations in Arabic and so but
then I was surrounded by okay so you
ever have to get yourself into that
situation either by having as
the case when I was learning Chinese I
was in a non Mandarin speaking
environment in Hong Kong but I had three
hours a day with teachers and the
teachers would organise dinners lunch
with our teachers so we had lots of
opportunity to speak manner if I had a
community of Farsi speakers here or
Arabic speakers when we got together
once or twice a week for dinner and so
forth that would create more of an
opportunity to really get into speaking
but even a little bit of speaking that I
do with my tutors it helps it it
increases it improves the quality of my
my focus and it gives me sort of
learning content you know that I can go
back to and go back to and I'm just
gonna quickly demonstrate that and oh if
I find the one where we talked about
language learning you'll see that it
contains a lot of phrases that kind of
reflect my philosophy on all of this and
if I find that I might even read it to
you in Arabic and then we can open it up
for questions so I'm gonna share the
screen so let's go back I don't know
which one this wasn't it but fee let's
go to lessons so you see I have 35
conversation reports in Arabic and
you'll also see here some of the other
things that I have been doing al Jazeera
podcast which is still difficult but I
still plow through them as email which
I'd not really like the content very
much but I do it B of who is she with
fonts that cut yeah but if I go into my
conversation reports so goes right back
to August so I've had all of these
conversation reports I can open up any
one of them and go in and relive the
discussions that I had
recently I stayed largely with Dahlia
who was a very good tutor and let me
just have a look like there was not
interesting because I was reviewing it
and it talked about language learning
no let's see if I find it quickly I'll
go over with you if I don't find it then
we just leave it so games
one more try and that's not that we just
scratch it oh yeah so what has happened
is she sent me a report I imported as a
lesson and so I can read it I can hear
her I'm not gonna do it but I can hear
her read it I can download it to listen
away from it and so who not she on via
it is so difficult
damn Renata Renata Thea hey Monica Thea
fee maja aleem Lula head so there are
things that are illogical in the
teaching of languages I agree with that
an ass people enough you you a key Doon
more Akhtar min Allah so they confuse
things or make things more complicated
than necessary anyway I won't go through
the whole thing but it talks about the
importance the things that I talked
about right now so we had a conversation
about the subject of the role of tutors
and the importance of motivation and so
and so on so I get a lot of this
vocabulary and I can listen to it over
and over again and it's not that long
like it's three minutes long will I
remember all those words no but it's a
start
it's a start and those words may come up
somewhere else and eventually eventually
they will swap you know kick it so
enough of that now
let me go back I wanted one thing I
wanted to show you by the way okay so
one of the things that I talk about that
I think is very important in language
learning is to cover the same material
in different ways
so I'm on my iPad a lot thought I also
like books and I like different books
and often starting in language I'll have
two different started books and I tended
to go to teach yourself
colloquial sometimes Escamilla but I was
in downtown Palm Springs and I decided
that I wanted to go to the local
bookstores I went to Barnes and Noble to
find out what they had in Arabic and a
book which I bought Arabic food almonds
and it's actually quite good I liked the
way they presented things a lot of what
they present it's what's so great about
it is when when you buy a book and it
kind of reinforces things that you kind
of are starting to realize or to know
and you get it again and of course it's
in a different form so it's it's sort of
a combination of repetition and fresh
and new and so I find myself more
receptive to that but what I wanted to
point out is it says here right on the
cover find three conversational audio
tracks online I don't know if you read
that but that's what it says fine free
audio tracks online so buried in here
somewhere
sort of look through this but where do I
find these audio tracks and if I go to
this website dummies
whatever Arabic for dummies free
download I know they're there is no
place where you can download audio
so of course it's contact us so I go to
contact us on of course it's you as
always happen you get to some free
frequently answered question list
I don't want frequently answered crust
because no matter what you punch in
there as your question they know it
always come back with sorry no
information I managed to find a place
where there's a live chat so I get on
with someone and chat and I say I bought
this book I want to access the free
audio Oh what was the ISBN number do I
find the ISBN number and I said I'm
going out now but you send me an email
tell me where I can get the audio so I
come back and there's a not there's an
email that says sorry that was a mistake
in the book we don't offer free honor
like how is that possible how is it
possible to sell a book which has three
things on the cover that that want to
entice you to buy the book including
find free conversational audio tracks
online and when you contact them they
say that's a mistake
that's unbelievable anyway with that I
will now move on to questions all right
I mean I just can't believe that a
presumably reputable publisher could do
something like that okay first one stop
kkkkk that supposed to be laughter made
what's good today my language found me
on everyone is really just a big kid I'm
learning Indonesian Cambodian Vietnamese
well I'm kind of busy okay so far okay
lots of comments okay anyway you guys
care about good listening to your vote
on this forum post ok playlist playlist
yeah the playlist I'm not quite sure
what the vote is all about but we are
going to do things to make the playlist
work better I think the what we are
going to do I don't want to Priya but
it's gonna get better
I don't think URLs and YouTube chats
works okay other features over that
exact night
okay so the hundred playlist limit I
think what we're gonna do is right now I
have a number of problems with the
playlist if I add new items to the
playlist
they're often scattered throughout the
playlist so I can't find them
but realistically we don't need more
than 100 items on the playlist at any
one time so I think what should happen
is that as we add more items to the top
that's it to the to the bottom the ones
at the top are simply kicked off the
playlist if we want to but they sort of
stay there and then if you delete stuff
then they will come back in more complex
yeah here I would also be willing to pay
extra for a separate app with more
complex playlist features like I'm in
favor of albums in the playlist but for
whatever reason whether it be resources
programming resources or you know server
resources I don't know there seems to be
some resistance to this but put all your
ideas on the forum
play next play later features okay I
mean these are all good some their limit
is room okay also maybe a reminder
feature to review a course in either one
week or two weeks
links are you doing wonders all right
okay
yeah listen these are all great ideas
Eric who's watching taking notes and we
will see what we can do now okay so far
lots of back-and-forth banter you
mentioned about how you study if you
have more tonight okay question how
would you study here four hours a day
hey if I had four to five hours a day so
the idea is that whatever activity we're
doing we get tired of doing it so if I
have one hour I can listen 45 hour 45
minutes wherever I am and do a bit of
reading and linky if I have more time I
would probably spend more time reviewing
in the vocabulary section I would have
more online discussions with my tutor
would I translate well in my activities
I would certainly do the dictation
function where I hear the word and then
I have to type it I would do all five
activities I tend to now go through my
flashcard review very quickly I would
spend more time on that so I would just
introduce more different activities when
you said I would I translate I don't
think I would translate other than that
our flashcards we do have call it
reverse reverse flash cards also you can
use that like the activity section if
you save phrases and get rid of the
words in a given lesson and you just
work on phrases then you can have all
those phrases there and you can do them
all in reverse try it in reverse flash
card so you would have to translate all
these phrases and these phrases would
then also show up in your dictation so
you would hear the phrase and you would
have to type so I would experiment
different ways link teachers I talk
tomorrow he's gonna he's looking at he
has a friend who does stuff of this
nature and he's gonna look at what we
can do to come up with some kind of a
thing about t-shirts is we you know we
have to whatever we do we have to do
equally for you know men and women so I
don't know whether women are less
inclined to wear t-shirts with a logo or
with I don't know if people can
volunteer their ideas on that sunny
hello from Serbia okay hi everyone from
Russia Dmitry I can't wait for like
tisha nurse from Bahrain okay I'm just
enjoying my learning Arabic thanks for
speaking clearly calling it Persian yeah
someone caught me up on that and I like
the word Persian I mean Farsi is the
Persian word for Persian and it probably
comes from Arabic Rasha ha ha so again
okay this is yeah I personally like
learning more than one language at the
same time tabla hello alpha personal
preference hello okay so a lot of
comment stephen krashen says to drink
more coffee to learn languages well
first of all I had my coffee and I'm now
drinking tea stephen krashen is
convinced the coffee delays the
possibility of you know Alzheimer's I
don't know if that's true or not I think
coffee is a good drink and if you like
it make coffee I doubt if it has any
noticeable effect on your language
learning do you feel you are comfortable
with speaking Russian and do you still
use it I mean I don't use it much
obviously I am rarely run into anyone
who speaks Russian yeah I mean
comfortable enough I will be going as I
said earlier I will be going to Ukraine
and I'll be speaking a lot of Russian
there and I'm not concerned I will do
fine I would be a little bit rusty at
first but yeah it's it just makes it to
my top 10 you know like it's not at the
level of my Japanese French Spanish
German Swedish but it's up there an
interesting thing is while I speak
languages like Swedish or German better
I have a larger vocabulary in Russia
because I've been you know I read that
Russian so very deliberately but I
haven't spoken as much so the speaking
will be a little bit rusty ah if you're
a c2 does the learner still need to have
tutor sessions or is it isn't it more
necessary well if you're c2 like if I'm
c2 I would not like I'm not seek to in
anything except possibly French but I'm
sort of strong b2 c1 and you know
Japanese job
I don't have tutors for those I feel
that I've reached a level that I can't
go forward what should I do
question if you want and are you out of
level or you're satisfied or you're out
of love where you would like to go
forward but you can't if you're at a
level where you're good in the language
you are in the soft spot you're in the
sweet spot rather you can just keep
enjoying the language watching movies
reading books listening to stuff and you
will constantly improve what's the
problem that's good what is your opinion
about Russian people okay
there was a famous man called Jonathan
Swift who he wrote the Gulliver he did
thanks Gulliver's Travels he said that I
hate all Frenchmen but I like Monsieur
so on so I hate all lawyers but I like
so but the point is any time you make
generalizations about people the
generalizations are are going to are
going to tend towards caricature my
impression of Russian people is that
they are extremely warm interesting
lively creative you've only to see them
in in hockey which I like in in the arts
the quality of audio books for example
from Russia the quality of their
theatrical productions all of these
things are absolutely excellent the
there are political problems today and
you know in different countries people
are influenced by their political
environment and this can sometimes
create friction is with other countries
let me just leave it there is it
actually possible someone reached situ
in a language learned in adulthood or is
it just unrealistic no I think it's
absolutely realistic to reach situ in
but it does require a lot of reading and
listening like I learned French in no I
had French at school but my Chinese
which I started today is whatever for 21
or my Japanese I'm not c2 but if I set
myself a goal of reaching C - I can do
it and it would require a lot of
listening reading really expanding vocab
you like you have to have a large
vocabulary
you've got to approach the vocabulary of
a native speaker and you have to be in
situations where you have to use the
language a lot so probably you would
have to go to the country because to bc2
is not enough to have a good accent and
to sound fluent on a limited number of
subjects you've got to be the full
government you've got to be able to read
literature you've got to be able to
express yourself elegantly and so this
requires a massive amount of input and
probably to live in the environment and
does your Barbara speak Persian okay my
Barbara at home in Vancouver it's very
funny because I have been going to a
barber who was a Russian speaking
Ukrainian so I go there to meet speak
Russian
but then I went there twice and his shop
was closed and I wasn't happy with him
anyway so there's another barber in West
Vancouver so I phone up and this woman
answers with the most you know
noticeable Persian accent on her English
so I say wow that's great
so I said I'm coming over to get my
haircut Jesus fine so I go over there
and I greet her by you know hold it to
30
and she said how did you know I was
Persian like your accent she didn't
think she had an accent
she met in Canada over 20 years that's
fine I wanted to focus on my blah blah I
think a start yeah okay lots of back and
forth here so what
and the tutor is not teaching well the
tutor doesn't teach if I were to have
read that text in Arabic Kluber is there
to encourage provide some explanation
but there's lots of explanation you can
find your own explanation don't expect
the tutor to teach you the tutor is
there to encourage you motivate you
stimulate you get you going if you don't
like your tutor find another tutor it's
important to like your tutor it's
important to like the content you're
listening to it's important to like them
voice you're listening to it's important
to like the subject matter it's
important to do things that you like if
you don't like you to find another tutor
[Music]
for me practically the only subject that
you shouldn't discuss with your tutor
when learning languages is learning
languages is counter it causes
interference between the language course
I have absolutely no idea what you're
talking about and I think the more
familiar the subject is the more
suitable it is for a conversation
because you're interested in the subject
that you're familiar with the subject
even if you don't have the words you can
get into the conversation if you talk
about something that you don't know
anything about it's a lot more difficult
so no I don't agree with that Pesci not
for a minute
she was a young property getting this a
little bit of sake here and there doctor
after friends okay okay I'm a native
speaker of Russian if anyone wants to be
freedivers exchange Russian Fifi okay
you're interested with this have you
considered to learn their nation you
know my course physio with all due
respect you keep on coming at me with
the same pressure
why don't I learn Tagalog why don't I
learn other I'm gonna learn the
languages that I'm interested when I'm
interested in there is no why
whatever at some point if I meet someone
Indonesian of friend motivates me we
have Indonesian now at Lake Indian Asian
mini stores I was in Bali once
also been to Jakarta if I were going
there I would learn it Tim has kept you
I finally made it it seems like they're
inspiring a lot of people ok
oh yes Tim who motivated me to do these
work ups ok so my goal Eva Steve would
you say listening in your sleep to
podcast conversation that you're
learning is beneficial absolutely not
when I sleep I sleep I can't imagine
having podcasts on while sleeping I do
occasionally speak different languages
in my dreams the beginner resorts you
find useful when you learn rush ok
I started Russia and that before we have
link and and in fact very soon
thereafter or before we had Russian on
very soon thereafter we got rush no I
think I had a Russian employee I got him
to translate and record who is she
but I use teach yourself I used
colloquial I have a tendency to get any
of these starter books two or three of
them cover the same material and then it
was just you know as soon as I could I
remember my first novel law as the
Kreutzer Sonata by Tolstoy for which I
got the audiobook big advantage with
Russian is there's so many high quality
audio books of basically 19th century
doctors free if it's 20 essentially you
can find you just buy the e-book and
bring it into link but to get started I
would I would what I did was I used the
most common I also bought a similar so I
used the most common starter material as
well as whatever we have a link have you
thought what are the major have you
thought about trying to read a history
book in Arabic or Farsi I'm not yet
there yeah one of the things that really
helped me in Chinese is a book at a sort
of early intermediate level on Chinese
history and civilization so if there
were a resource with audio in Arabic or
Farsi that talked about history
civilization but it was a little
simplified and it had audio that would
be great
otherwise it's just a tad difficult the
Persian online resource has a fair
amount of good stuff in in Persian have
you ever thought about working with even
like filter from so that for example if
I buy his material he gives me a code
that automatically unlocks the content
link very good idea filter has great
material absolutely you've recommended
real polished pl we have an approach
filter I see see what we could do in
regard interesting thought
we haven't approached different
publishers to sell their material across
link Piatra has given us a bit of his
stuff many publishers do that they'll
give us a few sample lessons and then
encourage people to go to their site
anyone learning polish should know
Piatra and real polish dot pl yeah and
so again yeah jump into authentic
content as soon as possible of course
it's easier to do in some less languages
of others even in Greek it's not too bad
but in Arabic and Persian because the
writing system is just a little more
difficult yeah Phil Kehoe I think that's
a great idea and I will Eric a link
please make an order that we should have
approached filter brother Steve I'm an
English teacher from Spain and your
ideas in link have made me change
dramatically where I teach and learn I'd
love to use in class but now we lost
them okay so here are some ones so at
any rate anyone who wants to use link in
the classroom please contact us you can
send an email to me Steve at link we
have a special sort of link in the
classroom package that we can work and
we have some teachers in schools that
are using it in that way somebody here
Jim points out the person comes from
Greek Farsi comes from Persian
right however you know it's like Farsi
means Persian so since the word the
adjective for the country in English is
Persian
then we should call the language Persian
just like we call German German we don't
call it dirt even though the Germans
call their own language Deutsch oh here
we all do Goethe is the publishing
industry the education system a tough
nut to crack
I know I know question what are your
thoughts on the aja TT method I get that
question every time and I used it I
cannot comment Oh link laptop stickers
all right you know one thing I was
thinking of but you know because I have
the air pot and something is like I was
on my bicycle and my ear pod fella so I
thought that's not very good so then I
found out that you can actually get
little attachments to your ear pods so I
looked them up but there's no place to
put a logo but it would be nice to have
something with a link logo that relates
to how people study so laps top flap top
sticker something on your iPad iPhone
that's good idea have you ever used the
Mina Mina on your hova textbook no I
have not sorry when I was learning
Japanese it I had heard of it I used
Naga Numa would you agree that doing
around on a language exam does not
necessarily mean you can speak it
absolutely I agree with that 100% you
know in english-speaking Canada kids
have depending on the province ten years
of friendship school in the regular
system leaving aside the the immersion
and the better kids pass they do well
and all their French exams and they
can't speak so it's kind of it's up it's
it's it's ridiculous really because if I
were teaching languages in school I
would focus entirely on input discovery
comprehension not producing the language
because you can study for a test and get
something right and then two weeks later
you've completely forgotten
whereas things that are put in
your brain through massive input
listening and reading it's it's the case
you can retrieve it eventually you
Rebecca they're coming to you just for
talking developing an ability to listen
to listen and speak or for correct
grammar questions no I don't rely on one
this is Felipe
I don't rely on the tutor for grammar if
the tutor finds something that I you
know like very often in our tutor report
I ask the tutor to do two things first
of all to give me phrases sentences
sentences so much as phrases and words
that I have trouble with or that come up
in our conversation but then if there is
a grammar issue that I keep on getting
wrong then shell point that I go work on
and this both my tutor do let's go work
on this aspect of the language so there
can be some I would say the biggest
thing is the stimulus an opportunity to
speak an opportunity to develop a
rapport which is then input that I could
go back to again them again and there
will be the odd grammar correction but
it's not the main purpose I see some
Hebrew there I I stopped my Hebrew so do
you agree that Russian and German focus
is amazing I agree that all folk music
is amazing I love Spanish folk music
down here in Palm Springs will sometimes
hear Mexican on the local radio Mexican
music Peruvian music yes I can't
remember I mean all you know Greek music
you name it they're all amazing how am I
gonna study for how to make a plan to
study French from scratch any language
from scratch you you got to start to get
the like a toehold in the language so
get some starter books did you get on
the material we have it link just let's
start out with short 30 seconds and then
grabs the 1 minute 2 minute 5 minutes
and you just this process of listening
and reading and reviewing words and
slowly what seems a lot of noise at
first and where you can hardly tell work
one or word ends and the next word
begins slowly slowly slowly
it starts to
like a jigsaw puzzle as I said the other
day it starts to make sense how to not
feel bored I'm never bored I find the
initial period in learning a language is
quite exciting because all of sudden you
can say something okay now what are you
doing Anna I'm going to Japan in the
fall
I'm not going to mccrane in May no yes
my grandkids speak English for the
British accent what is the minimum
amount of time you should spend in my
country to improve your ability in
language you don't have to spend any
amount of time can prove your ability I
just said to be a seat - you cannot have
to go to Kentucky you can do a lot on
your own
minimum time I mean I in the case of
check I study for a year and then I
spent six or seven days I think six days
in Prague trying to do a lot of speaking
it's whatever you're able to arrange if
you are studying the language you are
motivated to go there and motivate them
to spend as much time as you can do you
think online tutors will replace
personal teachers I think there will be
more and more there are more and more
online tutors no person does not come
from meet my from Asian person where
cars yeah ancient Greeks what right what
do you think about I talkie and I don't
know cambly but I talk I've used it a
lot it's very good they have some
excellent - is it better to have native
tutors or non-native tutors as well okay
the tutor personally I would not use a
non-native puter well let me back that
up if it if the tutor is close to me
like at the very least you know because
it part of it is a sort of emotional
thing so I could see he's speaking to it
a second good same learning Perea and I
have a second generation korean-american
who who speaks Korean 99% like a native
speaking Korean I would use that for
I would not learn Korean from a say
Caucasian American or African American
no matter how well they spoke the
language because I don't know at some
level I want to have the sense that I'm
dealing with the source not fair
but you asked me my question by my
perspective because it's largely about
motivation hello people the Farseer
comes from Persian okay do you think in
the language that you are fluent in now
or do you think in English that I
mentioned you know this question has
come up before I certainly when I was
speaking the language that I speak
really well I'm basically going in the
language but there's always some amount
of translating from English and in the
languages that I speak well that's a
very small amount and the languages that
I don't speak so well it's a larger it's
a gradual progression how many hours
does it take to listen and read a day
well I listen as many you know as much
as I am able to do I always multitasker
I'll always listen when I'm doing
something else so any activity that
allows me to listen driving exercising
washing the dishes going for walk the
best vanilla and then I try to get in
another hour or so of reading I learned
faster three years I learned in math
grammar I can write essays however I
can't speak at all what is the approach
to improve my listening there am i
speaking you know honestly you I like
listening
I like the many stories which have a lot
of the high frequency verb if you can
get a handle on those key verbs it gets
you started speaking and then you have
to find people to speak to and you have
to speak a lot but in order to express
things you have to get into the rhythm
of some of the more frequent verbs go
come get take need one hole that way you
start to build something
and yeah that's what I would do lots of
listening and then lots of speaking and
try the many stories of the link how do
you choose a language to learn whatever
I'm motivated by so we were gonna go to
Crete so I learned Greek we were in
Israel I started preparing you know
trying to learn some Hebrew didn't have
enough time added to make much progress
but then I when I went to Jordan and I
just felt Arabic was you know more
interesting because there's so many more
people speaking it
we have FARC's person speakers in
Vancouver so then I say well if I got
Arabic and Persian then why not Turkish
it just kind of flows one from the next
I have no plan I imagined a party eBooks
get foreign language ebooks without DRM
you know the books that I have imported
polish books Ukrainian books even there
are some Arabic teaching materials that
weren't very good but I imported them
you have to experiment but it depends
what the language is I have a question
about being indifferent what do you
think are the lesson on major diplomatic
languages besides the obvious English
French and Spanish I don't know but you
have you could start at the UN
so obviously Chinese and Russian I mean
there are very strong regional languages
I mean Russian if you want to talk about
geographically like obviously all of the
Russian Federation plus Central Asia
former Soviet Union many people in
Eastern Europe
so Russian is a pretty strong regional
language Arabic is a big regional
language Indonesian Malaysian is a big
regional language Swahili I don't know
much about I forget about Swahili I
think at least in East Africa is a big
regional language so these would be some
of the regional languages in other words
when you say diplomatic languages you
mean languages that are spoken the
outside the border of their country did
you learn parents Pali and a difficult
language ok so I mean my polish is not
very good
but I mean I can read it I can
understand it I was speaking at some
extent when I was working on it I did a
90 day challenge in Polish but having
got a Russian Ukrainian and the Czech
polish is not very difficult polish has
some things that are different from
those other languages the vocabulary
actually Ukrainian polish the vocabulary
is quite close all right
are you learning Russian da da da you
can use for vote Chrome extension or
fart inferred okay I will look into that
I have not found any text to speech for
Farsi for Persian no he's gone 7 do you
think link will last another 53 years
link will last longer than I won't last
okay my son is in charge of link bingo
Steve any reason all can't remember how
we came up with that I've been learning
Mandarin Chinese for over 10 years and I
enjoy it a lot I'm not great but I've
tried the issue is people say you just
have a talent but I feel it undermines
new effort thoughts yeah I very much
dislike the people as all you just have
a town like the number of people who's
quickly dismissed language as well you
have a talent I have no talent I wasn't
good as you know languages at school so
but then you know people who say that to
me then I say well how many people
wouldn't would you do what I'm doing
will you spend so much of your time
reading and listening I mean you ask my
life how much time I spend on liners
right I mean any free moment that I'm
doing something else I'm listening to
the language how many people do that so
I think that language I go back to
Catalan they great Hungarian polyglot of
the previous century and she said
language is your motivation or your
attitude plus Time / inhibition
frustration and stuff like that so
anybody can do that
anybody can be motivated to learn can
put in the time and as long as they
minimize resistance frustration
inhibition they will learn some will
learn maybe a little faster than others
some might be better at pronunciation
some might be better at remembering
vocabulary but everyone can and it
doesn't require a special talent because
we all learn our first language do you
live in the Philippines inspire us all a
lot about what men enter here do you
agree that Arabic is more beautiful than
Hebrew you gotta be a little careful you
know until we learn the language some
languages don't sound very attractive
okay
I used to think that Cantonese wasn't
very attractive until I started speaking
it then I get into the the enjoyment of
the language on the surface Hebrew
doesn't sound very attractive I would
say on the surface it Arabic doesn't
sound very attractive now that I've
started speaking some Arabic I enjoy it
I find it very strong you know so you
start enjoying it so I don't want to
make judgments about a language that I
haven't that I don't really speak hello
that first time I gave you life I'm
Brazilian kind of trying to learn
Japanese
gives me inspiration good I'm glad that
that has I got a book under my gear the
Dyckman said this has no pages or gives
you the answers at the back can I find I
don't know that we have lots of material
I think your spouse who is a native
speaker the language you're learning is
it better to still use a tutor or to
decide and to see what progress can be
made at each spot okay my experience
with my own sponsor my wife yeah but I
decided to learn Cantonese and she was
not helpful very difficult if you have a
spouse girlfriend boyfriend whatever and
you're used to speaking a certain
language it's very difficult to change
those house but if you can make it work
go for it I mean it's obviously a very
good resort can you reach a native level
without living in comfort without
language people say you can't teach
there
I've lived in the zoo with the animals I
mean it's I don't want to say never but
it's it's a big advantage you can reach
a very high potential level without
going to the country but to get to that
there's no level I think you have to
live their language or in terms of
business and making money it depends
where you are depends what business
you're in I couldn't answer that
question I am a non-native theatre where
you taught me how to learn German and
Chinese on my own all right that's good
hey guys what's up I have used petition
I'm not a big hugger and Friends persons
yes I mean aggression is if you're with
people and they're talking very quickly
amongst themselves it's going to be
difficult to understand what they're
saying if you have good friends then I
would get them to record these
conversations where they use their you
know frequent express lens transcribe it
and then listen to it listen to it and
read it okay reminder I heard for them
did their consider changing the other
country any foreign language singers you
like well I mean I like music all the
kinds of music you know we were in we
were in Lisbon you know I'm a yellow
tree I guess you know father owes me a
mature yeah yeah Julio Iglesias whatever
I like Oh music
okay yeah when you the mini-stories I
must say even though I was involved in
creating them I didn't write them we
have a person write them I find that it
really prepares you for speaking I am
speaking in Persian and Arabic much
earlier than I ever did let's say in in
Czech or polish because it gives you the
verb it gets you in a position where you
can start saying something so very
definitely but it's still not a very
long way into the language because you
need so much vocabulary ultimately but
at least you can get started talking to
people and with the tutor so I would say
yes my experience has been that the mini
stories enabled me to start with a tutor
much earlier do you think reading marx
engels lenin and trustee and german will
massively help my german dependence what
you're interested in you know if you
enjoy reading those things and go for it
I wouldn't I I find I have to be
interested in and find that what I am
reading is of value
I don't think reading Marx Engels Lenin
Trotsky in any language is of any value
any thoughts about Latin I had Latin at
school the argument is that it helps
prepare you for other learning other
languages if you want an an entry
language into the Romance languages I
think that should be Spanish because
it's also useful today if you want to
learn a language in order to encourage
you to learn languages I would say
Esperanto would be the language because
it's easy to learn apparently I haven't
learned it I'm not motivated to learn it
but if kids at school learned Esperanto
and gained a sense of confidence that
they can learn languages then that would
be a good thing let's see what do you
recommend in to learning a language
where it's less popular and that's more
difficult no you have to look for it I
look for content for Romanian I look for
content for Ukraine II yeah you just
have to look Google what do you think
people tell you nothing article and
because it's useless yeah
I mean there are lots of language
chauvinists out there when I was with
some Russian speaking Russian people in
Vancouver and I said I'm learning Czech
now oh I'll give her a knee jerk is only
ten many people it's useless no you
learn the language you're interested in
it's not a matter what's useful or
useless what does it mean to be at a
native language in the language native
level yeah native level is the same as a
native not very many people are gonna
achieve that hey what what would you say
you remember more is listening to audio
that's doing it when you read or by
searching words you encounter when you
no no I
I learned the words mostly about reading
if I hear them I don't get them and then
I do a bit of reviewing and then if I
see that work and the first time I see
it I save it as a link it's not yellow
next time I see it I forgotten that were
even seen the word before but over time
as it shows up more and more in what I'm
reading it starts to click it and the
audio reinforces that sorry do you agree
that only world socialism ok I don't
want to get into plenty oh this guy from
here I've asked a similar question where
I'm just wondering why link doesn't have
any we now have someone who has
volunteered to do the mini stories in
hindi we're working with him or her if
that takes if that happens we will have
India think it's all a function of
availability of content for link we
don't create our own content so we are
we do they offer some compensation for
people who are willing to create and the
very least the 60 mini stores so we're
now looking at Georgian Hindi Hungarian
the people are apparently working on and
then will be added to link do you agree
that it is easier to learn languages
when you are rich and have lots of free
time and and your hands and don't have
to work for a living which sources does
not resolve this look I don't want to
get into a discussion on socialism I
don't think that I don't know what the
word socialism means
more you mean social welfare social
hello socialized medicine do you mean
the Soviet Union I don't know that
language skills in the People's Republic
of China in the old days or in the
Soviet Union or particularly developed I
don't know I think it's irrelevant I one
of the most multilingual countries in
the world apparently is Ethiopia I don't
think they're particularly wealthy there
so no answer your question no can you
learn French quickly if you already know
Spanish not quickly but you have some
advantages what did you think is the
what do you think okay what do you think
is the best thing that the field of
computational linguistics has achieved I
have not a clue
probably text-to-speech and and where
you call it the automatic translation
which is very useful what is the artists
letter to pronounce in Arabic Arabic
it's this law that comes at the end of
some words sometimes it's it's
pronounced ah sometimes oh I find I'm
still trying to get a handle on Oh Steve
can I have a tutor from YouTube because
all the teachers and I'm using it
currently is on YouTube sure wherever
you're fine okay I see me oh I think it
has a great reputation so obviously a
lot of people really like it the Persian
us email is very good because they
actually give you the vocabulary for
each lesson I don't like it when they
only give you the translation it's more
distracting to have to read through the
translation to get the meaning some of
them are good some are like it's just
another source of content I don't think
there's anything particularly
spectacular about us email as compared
to teach yourself or colloquial would
you show us how you google for contents
in any language okay what you have to do
is you say okay Paul is history
okay if you google polish history you
won't get anything so you then go to
Google Translate and translate that into
Polish history in Polish and
you can add audio book or ebook and then
you Google and that will then come up
that bring up a lot of stuff if you're
at an earlier stage than you probably
will do it in your own language like
Portuguese or in English and you might
simple stories in whatever so you have
to experiment with putting it up either
in your own language or in English
English would give you access to more
stuff or translate it into the target
language do you think it's bad to learn
languages to impress and gain respect
from people no and in any reason to
learn languages is good but if your
motivations primarily to impress people
you won't go very far
thank you very much and I will end it
here bye for now